dramatische entwicklung im königreich
bayern ich weiß gar nicht ob das schon
alle bürger mitgekriegt haben da unten
in den schluchten und dörfern jedenfalls
zieht seit tagen ein minnesänger über
die marktplätze und verkündet die frohe
kunde christian ehring tan dardai und
aufgemerkt irrtum bei waren sehe die
düsteren zeichen vögel fallen tot vom
himmel murmeltiere 10 sie in ihre
erdlöcher zurück und uli hoeneß gibt vor
schreck eine korrekte steuererklärung
haben alles nur weil der söder kommt
jahrelang hatte der junge thronfolger
renke geschmiedet um den greisen
herrscher aus dem amt zu drängen
hier der moment des machtwechsels mit
laiendarstellern nachgespielt
ja es waren übrigens die exakten worte
von söder endlich auf dem gipfel der
macht und wenn ihr euch jetzt fragt wie
hat er das bloß geschafft dieser
telefonzellen große höhlen troll aus
franken wo das tomaten brot noch tomaten
brot heißt ja das geschäft mit der
mächtigsten waffe unserer zeit facebook
einfach gnadenlos jeden scheiß ins netz
blasen der karpfen köpfe ist zur
fränkischen tradition dazu die hälfte
aller karpfen deutschland wird kommt aus
bayern aus franken oberpfalz hallo ich
schwimme kosten hat sensationell die
quietsche ist das zeichen dafür dass der
spanier total frisches wissen viele gar
nicht
und noch viel mehr interessiert es gar
von morgens bis abends ist der söder
über die dörfer getingelt und hat das
csu folgt mit geld und drohungen auf
seine seite gezogen deswegen reitet er
jetzt hoch verdient in die münchner
staatskanzlei ein könig markus der
hinterletzte er lebe hoch
das arme pferd freudig bavaria auf das
was nun kommt unter den neuen regenten
die umfragewerte der csu aktuell bei nur
37 prozent werden innerhalb von tagen
hochschnellen auf 73 sogar die afg
protestwähler kommen zurück aufs nackte
angst vor söder und natürlich wird er
nächstes jahr auch parteichef werden
sonst seehofer seehofer kriegt ein neues
büro in berlin und alexander dobrindt
kriegt endlich einen job der seinen
fähigkeiten entspricht als ulkiger
trottel abo des königs alles wird gut
alles wird wo bliebe bei waren und
unsere feier des tages nun von mir alle
36 strophen von patrona bavariae patrona
bavariae hoch überm sternenzelt kommt
noch christian ehring meine damen und
herren
ja